[Musique]
les chercheurs on rêve tous faire une
découverte qui révolutionnera l'histoire
parfois le hasard donne un coup de pouce
ça a été le cas pour alexander fleming
ce médecin écossais qui a découvert la
pénicilline
une autre découverte fortuite pourrait
cette fois-ci révolutionner les maladies
neurodégénératives
[Musique]
non
tout commence il ya dix ans à l'époque
johann tschopp et fait des études
postdoctorales à l'université de
californie à san diego
sa mission bloqué dans une cellule
cancéreuse la production d'une protéine
appelée ptb cette protéine permet à
certains gènes de s'exprimer à la suite
d'une expérience ratée
inoubli une boîte de pétri rempli de
cellules cancéreuses
deux semaines plus tard il découvre la
boîte pleine de nouvelles cellules
incapable de les identifier
il consulte des collègues leur réponse
est sans équivoque
ce sont des neurones
[Musique]
théoriquement il est impossible de
régénérer un neurone ni de reconstituer
un circuit neuronal la boîte de pétri
enr et l éthique contaminés
pour le vérifier l'étudiant recommence
l'expérience chaque fois le même
résultat
lorsqu'il retire la protéine péter
bethune cellules cancéreuses
celle-ci se métamorphose en neurones
[Musique]
informé de ces découvertes le directeur
du département de médecine cellulaire et
moléculaire de l'université de
californie à san diego
qian dans nos fous prend la relève il
pousse les recherches plus loin
après une valse des ses erreurs de
directeur parvient à développer à virus
non infectieux qui une fois à
l'intérieur d'une cellule réduit au
silence le gène qui produit la protéine
ptb
il injecte ensuite ce virus dans le
cerveau d'une souris atteintes de la
maladie de parkinson une maladie qui
affecte les neurones trois mois plus
tard le résultat est saisissant
le tiers des cellules sont convertis en
europe les niveaux de deux gamines sont
même rétabli l'équipe est parvenue à
renverser des symptômes de la maladie de
parkinson chez la souris
une découverte fortuite permettra-t-elle
un jour de concevoir un traitement pour
soigner les maladies neurodégénératives
chez les humains rappelons-nous qui
s'est écoulé une quinzaine d'années
entre la découverte de la pénicilline et
le début des sets chez certains blessés
en 1943 alors oui
il est permis d'espérer
[Musique]